[Music]
welcome back to cbs this morning
saturday
this week apple announced the rollout of
a new feature that's both winning praise
and raising concerns
the tool will scan photos and text
messages on apple devices
looking for known images of child sex
abuse
tom hansen looks at both the benefits
and the privacy issues raised by the new
technology
new controversy over apple's latest
software update
neural match the program scheduled for
rollout later this year will scan u.s
iphones for images of
child sex abuse apple's gone out of its
way to
make this as privacy friendly as
possible jim lewis is an expert in cyber
security
how exactly will this software work
there will be part of the program that
has access to data what they call hashes
of the imagery in other words
the picture reduced to a numeric formula
apple
will use that numeric formula to look
for
things images that match it on your
device
if there's a match the photos will be
shown to an apple employee
verified sensitive material will then be
forwarded to the national center for
missing and exploited children
and the user's icloud account will be
locked the move drawing both applause
and
outcry on twitter ashton kutcher
tweeting
it's a major step forward in the fight
to eliminate child sexual abuse material
from the internet
security watchdogs concerned the new
software could be exploited by hackers
and foreign governments
the head of whatsapp calling this a
major setback for personal privacy
tweeting
can the scanning software running on
your phone be error proof
researchers have not been allowed to
find out do you think that this could
potentially
put certain people under scrutiny from
law enforcement who don't deserve to be
apple program itself is designed in such
a way that the chances of it making a
mistake
of it saying something is child
pornography when it's not
are infinitesimally small i don't think
this is a serious threat to privacy for
better or
for worse do you think that
apple's move here will push other large
tech companies to follow suit i think
all the tech companies are looking at
ways to
deal with uh malicious content right
there's a lot of bad stuff on the
internet
and it's more than overdue that they try
and step in to change that
apple says its efforts to protect
children will evolve and expand
over time for cbs this morning saturday
tom hansen new york the reason
you understand yes the privacy concerns
sure you understand it's that age-old
debate the more the more
i guess things that we have the more
questions of privacy and you also
understand now that it's more likely
that other companies will jump in
they certainly will yeah